in previous videos we talked about how
as we exit the fourth century in the
three 90s the Emperor Theodosius he
actually splits the Roman Empire
we already had the city of
Constantinople being established as a
capital of the empire that was done by
Constantine in 324 the city previously
known as Byzantium but as we enter into
the fifth century there was an official
split between the Western Roman Empire
and the eastern Roman Empire they are
actually governed separately now also in
other videos we talk about the eventual
fall of the Western Roman Empire now one
thing to keep in mind sometimes when we
talk about the fall of the West it
somehow implies that there's no
governance left or there's no kingdoms
left and nothing could be further from
the truth
one of the reasons why the Western Roman
Empire fell is repeated attacks by
Germanic tribes and after the Western
Roman Empire was gone the Germanic
tribes for the most part took over on
the Italian peninsula you at first have
the Kingdom of Otto a sir but eventually
you have rule as especially as we get
into the late 5th century you have the
ostrogothic kingdom Ostrogoths
the eastern Goths the eastern dramatic
tribes here in North Africa you have the
Vandals another Germanic tribe here in
the Iberian Peninsula you have the
Visigoths the Western Goths yet another
Germanic tribe here you have the
Burgundians you have the Franks the word
France comes from the notion of land of
the Franks once again all of these are
Germanic kingdoms that took over where
before you had the Western Roman Empire
now as you can see from this map and
we've talked about it in previous videos
it was only the Western Roman Empire
that fell and fragmented and for the
most part came into the hands of these
Germanic tribes the eastern empire
continues on and it's often known as the
Byzantine Empire with its capital
at Constantinople now what we'll see is
that the Byzantine Empire lasts for
almost another 1,000 years but its
importance in the region diminishes for
most of that period it does have one
last hurrah so to speak with the reign
of Emperor Justinian Justinian is able
to come to power in 527 he comes into
power with the help of his uncle who's
the previous Emperor Justin and
Justinian is able to regain much of the
land that was lost to the Germanic
tribes over the course of Justinian's
reign as you can see they're able to
retake the Italian peninsula and much of
North Africa now things weren't always
easy for Justinian and they're very
difficult at the beginning of his rule
and they get hard near the end of his
rule as well in 532 their significant
rioting in Constantinople which is his
capital
it all starts around Chariot Racing and
the different groups or gangs that
support the different Chariot Racing
teams but it eventually becomes an
all-out revolt against Justinian and
many of Justinian's advisors and
including Justinian himself they're
afraid that they're going to be
overthrown and killed and they think
about fleeing Constantinople this is
only five years into his reign this is
in 532 and at that point his wife
Empress Theodora
stands up and becomes a very important
actor in history she has her famous
speech at the point in time when
Justinian and his advisors were thinking
about fleeing fear of death they thought
they were going to be overthrown and
here is that famous quote from Empress
Theodora the present occasion is too
serious to allow me to follow the
convention that a woman should not speak
in a man's council those whose interests
are threatened by extreme danger should
think only of the wisest course of
action not of kin
inventions in my opinion flight is not
the right course even if it should bring
us to safety it is impossible for a
person having been born into this world
not to die but for one who has rained it
is intolerable to be a fugitive may I
never be deprived of this purple robe
the purple robe signifying royalty being
an empress and may I never see the day
when those who meet me do not call me
Empress if you wish to save yourself so
she's talking to Justinian and
Justinian's advisors if you wish to save
yourself my lord there is no difficulty
we are rich over there is the sea and
there are the ships yet reflect for a
moment whether when you have once
escaped to a place of security you would
not gladly exchange such safety for
death as for me I agree with the adage
that the royal purple is the noblest
shroud so she's saying I would rather
die as an empress then tried to be a
fugitive and just try to live my life
the rest of my life somehow comfortably
and she's able to convince Justinian and
they're able to put down the uprising
quite brutally killing 30,000 of the
people who are rising up against them
now during that uprising much of
Constantinople is burned including the
main church the Hagia Sophia and it was
under Justinian's rule that the Hagia
Sophia gets rebuilt and it still exists
in what is now Istanbul today
Constantinople eventually gets renamed
Istanbul once it's conquered by the
Turks and it eventually gets turned into
a mosque and today it is a museum the
Hagia Sophia literally means holy wisdom
you might recognize the word sophia from
philosophy which literally means friend
of wisdom phyllis sophia now perhaps
what Justinian is most famous for is his
attempt to better codify a set of laws
the Roman Empire course always had laws
but Justinian got legal experts to go
and collect
the laws of the land to make them
consistent to throw out the laws that
are inconsistent to add new laws is
necessary and he did this over his
entire reign and he spread them and they
are often referred to as the code of
Justinian and they would have an
influence on the Byzantine Empire for
the next 900 years and even some
influence on some relatively modern
schools of law now as I mentioned before
the reign of Justinian is considered
really the high point of the Byzantine
Empire and even as we get into roughly
the second half of his reign things
start to slide downward and over the
next nine hundred years are just in a
state of decline
starting in the five 40s there's a
significant plague in the Byzantine
Empire some accounts I've seen show that
roughly 40% of Constantinople dies
significant chunk of the population of
the Byzantine Empire dies and that makes
it more susceptible to attack from the
various Germanic tribes throughout
Justinian's reign and well after
Justinian there's a there's constant
tension and often conflict between the
Sassanid persians in the east and then
as we go further on especially as we get
into the seventh and eighth century you
have the rise of islam
early Islamic empires are able to take
over the sassanids and significantly eat
into the Byzantine Empire and then even
some of the Germanic kingdoms in the
Iberian Peninsula and so this is taking
us now we're in the middle of the 8th
century and if we go further on we see
this once again gradual decline continue
on where you have further invasions into
the Byzantine Empire from Turkish Muslim
kingdoms or Turkish Muslim conquerors
all the way until we get to 1453 when
Constantinople itself falls to the Turks
and eventually gets renamed Istanbul